so I'm back in England now safe and
sound as you can clearly see which means
now I get to tell you about the second
half of my trip to Tanzania we're still
in the region of tango we went to visit
Bombo Hospital where we got to see some
of the really great work that's being
done there to try and deal with
malnutrition first leave me and my mum
went to a maternity class where they
talked about the importance of
breastfeeding and making sure the mother
that has enough nutrients because
obviously that feeds through into the
child and I mean I'm sure they talked
about a lot of other very interesting
stuff but the whole thing was in Swahili
so I didn't quite grasp all of it and
then we went to the maternity ward where
we saw these teeny tiny little babies
that have been born prematurely and
already malnourished because they just
didn't have enough nutrition while they
were still inside their mums and my
little sister Bridie was born
prematurely and so when she popped out
the doctors put her in a little heated
glass box called an incubator to
regulate her temperature but a bombay
hospital because they just don't have
the money to buy decent incubators
they've had to improvise
and so they've turned an entire room
into a giant incubator just using heated
light bulbs because that's the best that
they could do with what they have but
after the giant incubator stage provided
that the baby stabilized they're
introduced to kangaroo care which is run
by sister Josephine and is just it's
just make do with what you have and it's
absolute finest and it just warmed the
cockles of my heart here the tiny little
babies are placed onto their mothers
skin and because the human body is
incredible it recognizes the presence of
the babies and turns the mothers into
living incubators that regulate the
temperature of the little kids the
program by the way is funded directly by
Save the Children and it has
appropriately saved a lot of children it
saved the lives of 6,000 babies just
over the course of the last year it's
pretty good incredible next we got on
yet another tiny little plane and I got
to sit in the copilot's seat this time
which made me incredibly happy and we
arrived on the island of Zanzibar to
visit some schools in the area now my
mum is a primary school teacher and a
really good one too and so this is
really where she came into her element
and got to teach a couple of classes she
showed them a video of her class make
home and gave them drawings that her
kids have done for them writing
greetings in Swahili and then she
encouraged them to think and talk about
food well they eat and just as I was
starting to come to expect from this
trip not everybody in the class got to
have three meals a day in fact one kid
in particular Adam only got to have one
meal a day which was just some rice and
that's it and he
particularly touch my mum's heart as
well when he said that he wanted to
become a teacher like her it's the kind
of example really of an instance where
you just want to take little Adam home
and give him all of the food that he
wants because it's these kind of
personal stories that really do hit home
especially when you see them in person
but it's important to remember that Adam
is an example of a much bigger problem
and that is what the if campaign is
about I hope that you can see that this
issue is one that has become very
important to me and so if you would like
to help out the most important thing we
can do honestly is just make it clear to
the people who have the power to change
this that this is something that we care
about I'll put a link down here to a
petition that you can sign but just as
good is just talking about this publicly
here on youtube or on any of the other
websites just whatever way you can think
of thank you I really hope you can get
involved in this I also want to say
thank you to Rosie and dowdy it saved
the children for making this trip happen
and to Franklin as well for letting me
be your friend very nice of you that's
all goodbye joining Joey to ending
hunger thank you that's perfect thanks
Frank you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
this is my faith on my head on my
shoulders with eyes and a mouth